عشرات من المظاهرات والمسيرات والمهرجانات
التضامنيه مع اهل غزه والمستنير للحرب
الاسرائيليه الدمويه الوحشيه على سكان
القطاع نظمت في الجزر والمحافظات
الاندونيسيه في الايام الاولى للحرب نظمت
بعض المظاهرات باعداد قليله هنا امام
السفاره الامريكيه في جاكارتا ثم انتقلت
هذه المسيرات والتجمعات الحاشده الى
الساحه الوطنيه والى مدن كثيره في
الارخبيل الاندونيسيه اليوم وبعد اكثر من
هذه الحرب يعود المتظاهرون الدونسي باعداد
كبيره الالاف منهم جاوا امام السفاره
الامريكيه في جاكارتا ليبعثوا برساله
واحده المتحدثون هنا كانت رسالتهم واحده
مطالبه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بوقف
الدعم الكامل ومطالبتها بالضغط على
اسرائيل لوقف هذه الحرب والوصول الى هدنه
وانهاء هذه الحرب الدمويه هناك مطالب
واضحه بهذا الشان واستنكار للموقف
الامريكي هذا الموقف الشعبي متناغم مع
الموقف الرسمي وزيره الخارجيه الاندونيسيه
كانت قد تحدثت في جنيف قبل ايام ب مستنكره
مستنكره ما وصفته بازدواجيه المعايير في
التعامل مع حقوق الانسان وقالت ان هناك
انتهاكات صارخه لحقوق الانسان في غزه وان
ما يحصل هناك لا يمكن السكوت عنه من قبل
من يتعهد ويتحدث طوال هذا الوقت طوال
سنوات الماضيه عن حقوق الانسان وقالت بان
مجلس الامن قد فشل في اقرار قرار يوقف هذه
الحرب وطالب الاطراف التي قالت انها عاده
ما تملي على دول مثل اندونيسيا قضايا حقوق
الانسان ومعاير حقوق الانسان طالبتهم بان
يقفوا موقفا انسانيا هذه المره ويقفوا مع
كفاح الشعب الفلسطيني في مواجهه هذا
الاحتلال في مواجهه ما يحصل في غزه وكذلك
في الضفه نعلم ان مئات من الشهداء ايضا
ارتقوا في الضفه الغربيه وبالتالي هناك
احتجاج واسع في الشارع الاندونيسي ورغم
دخول هذه الحرب الشهر الثالث الا ان نرى
ان روح التضامن مع الفلسطينيين لم تخف ما
زالت هناك الكثير من برامج التضامن ستنظم
خلال الايام القادمه ونحن نتحدث اليكم
هناك برامج اخرى تنظم في جنوب جزيره
سولاوسي اقليم سولاوسي
الجنوبيه وكذلك في كلنتن وكذلك في اقليم
اتشي في مدينه القسماوي وتضامن عبر وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي لم يسبق له مثيل في في
تاريخ التضامن الاندونيسي مع القضايا
العربيه والاسلاميه
ياس
الزك